THE WAY HE GETS TO THE
THREE-POINTERS.
IT'S NOT JUST ONE WAY.
THAT'S WHAT'S SO AMAZING ABOUT
STEPH.
>> LET'S BRING REGGIE MILLER
INTO THE CONVERSATION OFF THE
CONVERSATION YOU HAD WITH
STEPHEN CURRY.
I KNOW THAT HAPPENED JUST BEFORE
THE SEASON BEGAN, CORRECT,
REGGIE?
>> CORRECT.
>> YOU HAD NO IDEA YOU'D BE
TEAMMATES ON THIS NIGHT, RIGHT?
YOU MADE IT.
>> HEY!
>> REGGIE MILLER!
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> YOU'RE ON THE LIST.
>> YOU'RE ON THE LIST, MAN.
>> WHOA!
SERIOUSLY, I -- OKAY.
WOW, I'M A LITTLE FLUSTERED
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW
THIS IS VERY SUBJECTIVE, AND I
LOOK AT THAT LIST BECAUSE YOU'RE
GOING TO GET INTO WHO DIDN'T
MAKE THE LIST.
THERE'S GREAT PLAYERS ON THIS
LIST.
LOOKING AT THE FIRST 50,
EVERYONE ABSOLUTELY DESERVES TO
BE ON THAT LIST, AND I WASN'T
GOING TO BE UPSET IF I WASN'T
BECAUSE I WOULD PUT MY RESUME UP
AGAINST ANYONE.